-Of course, we all saw the quote
about you not wanting to go to
the White House
right at the beginning,
but that was press you wer
doing months in advance.
-Mm-hmm.
-Were you taken aback by
the fact that all of a sudde
that was out there
and everybody knew that
and the lead-up, or did yo
have a sense it was coming
-I did not know it was coming.
Heads-up would have been
nice on that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
And I think everyone thought
I said it, like, you know,
that was, like, a pregame
right in the locker room,
which it wasn't,
But I didn't mind it at all.
-Yeah.
-I said it. I stand by it.
I'm not going
to the White House.
I'll say that again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Per my mom's request,
I've dropped the "F" word.
-You have dropped the "F" word
-Yeah.
-Oh, that's -- that was
her only request?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-That was her only request
-I think that's a very parenta
piece of advice on something
-Yeah. I know.
-I'm not gonna read them all
but, you know, there was -
he tweeted a lot about you
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's a three-tweet.
I felt bad because --
-I got a full three-tweeter.
-Full three-tweeter.
-Crazy.
-I only got three lines.
-Yeah.
But you got
a low-key compliment here.
-Yeah.
What's my low-key compliment
"Almost."
-"Almost no --"
[ Laughter ]
-I noticed that right away
I didn't even get
a low-key compliment.
-You know what? Yeah.
Here I am -- Here I am,
taking this as an insult.
This is a man who just sai
I got a little bit of talent
-Yes. You sure did.
He must have been off his game
-Off his game.
[ Applause ]
-You know what?
You have to remember. I just
want to point out the date
That was 2014.
He was a much nicer guy in 2014.
He got to sleep in his own bed
-The office has changed.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
You were at the ESPYs.
-I was.
-Which was, we were talkin
backstage, can be a fun night.
-It was.
-Who were some of the people -
I think the best part
of that night
is maybe meeting people
in different sports
or not even in sports at all
Who did you get to
rub elbows with?
-Oh, my goodness.
Well, I get to sit
next to my beautiful girlfrien
all the time -- Sue Bird.
-Sue Bird. Backstage as well
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's over there. Hi.
So that's really the highlight
-You guys looked fantastic
by the way.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Took a tequila shot
with Sandra Bullock.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Tequila shot
with Sandra Bullock.
That's a real thing right there.
-That was --
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I was like --
If anybody who knows me knows,
I'm terrible at taking shots
especially tequila.
-Really?
Now, see that's --
-I'm like, "Everything's fine.
Thank God it's small.
Normally, they come --
Like, they're that big.
-I'm so happy
that we finally figured ou
something I'm better at.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
There you go. Yeah.
-Here we're coming right
to the end of the interview,
I'm feeling pretty bad
about myself.
-Here we go. Yeah.
A little talent.
-Well, that's really exciting.
And now I think
one of the things that
is also good to point out
is you guys have --
There's a professional socce
league here in the States.
-Yes.
-You're gonna go back.
You play for Seattle.
And it will be really nice
I think, for the fans
who enjoyed and appreciate
the level of soccer
you guys are playing
that's happening right her
in the country.
-They can come watch us
everywhere.
There's teams
all over the country.
I play for the Reign.
Come watch us play.
Come in every city.
Come watch the national team
too.
But shout-out, NWSL,
shout-out, Reign FC.
I expect to see everybody there.
-And you're very good
with faces.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-You're very good.
-I'll remember all of you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you.
-Thank you so much
for making the time.
It was really a blast
to watch you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Megan Rapinoe, everybody.